Film Courage: In the Kickstarter video [for
CURRENT SEA] you have an image of a man fighting
off another man on the boat or there’s a
fight that takes place, so we see that [where
the movie is shot] it’s a turbulent environment.
With some of the filming that you’ve been
exposed to, are you worried about your own
personal safety?
Stephanie Lincoln: I’m worried about Christopher’s
safety all the time when he’s there and
I’m not there.
Christopher Smith: Really?
You never told me that.
Well my mom is, I know that much.
And now Stephanie.
You know, filming in Cambodia in particular
(I’ll just speak for that) because it’s
probably different in different countries
but you kind of get a pass a bit for being
a Westerner.
And you have a certain degree of protection
that locals don’t have.
And so a lot of journalists who are Cambodian,
a lot of environmentalists that are Cambodian
are either imprisoned or sometimes disappear
or there are some prominent cases of some
very public bad things happening that of course
never really get solved or tied to anybody.
It is a lot more dangerous for them than it
is for people like us going in.
However, when you are out on the open oceans,
a lot of things can accidentally happen and
actually we (in the course of making this
film) learned about a local Cambodian champ
fisherman who was hurt by a Vietnamese fisherman
and of course no one was held responsible
for that.
So there is a certain amount of danger for
sure and particularly on these boats, they
are really small and there’s not a lot of
places to run and hide, you can’t just run
away.
It’s like you’re stuck there.
There was a few moments which isn’t in the
Kickstarter video (it might not even be in
the film) but where we were out on patrol
and that’s what MCC calls it when they go
out an look for illegal fisherman, it’s
called Patrol.
Not to necessarily go looking but when they
kind of come in their area they’ll kind
of go out to try to stop them and they take
the nets.
And so when we do some of those things they
are usually at night because that is when
illegal fisherman are operating and they operate
without lights so you go out there and it’s
pitch black.
And Stephanie, when we went out there the
first time we had an encounter.
So then what happens is they’ll like kind
of creep up on the illegal fisherman and then
they will turn on their lights and start shining
lights on them.
But then the fisherman have brighter lights
that they shine back on you and they usually
fish in groups and so what they do is they
drop their nets and they start circling you
and there is lots of yelling in Khmer which
is the language of Cambodia.
And it’s actually really kind of scary!
It might not come off that way in the video,
but in the moment it’s like anything can
happen.
One time I was there (the second time) we
went out and we didn’t have the advantage…it
was a new moon so there was no light basically
and you could barely make out some shapes
and all of the sudden we pretty much realized
that we were surrounded four or five giant…actually
I think it might have been as much as seven
Vietnamese paratrawlers and you can hear on
the radio and their lights start to come in
when they see you…everybody knows who Paul
is [one of the subject’s in CURRENT SEA]
and what they do.
So they are on the lookout for Paul and that’s
why they travel in groups so then they can
kind of combat them better.
At that point they kind of surrounded us and
we actually moved away because we were worried
about getting too far away from…they have
a medium sized boat, a speed boat and a big
boat.
And if we were too far away from reinforcements
in the big boat then it could be an issue.
Nothing ended up happening that night, but
there are moments where…when it feels in
control, it’s not as scary.
But the moment where you feel that this has
now gotten out of control, that’s when your
warning bells go off.
Having said that, nothing has happened so
far.
I think that legally speaking like getting
in trouble with the people in charge of the
country there is some risk there in terms
of they could decide that they just don’t
want to tolerate us anymore and I don’t
think they would necessarily get us in trouble
but they could definitely kick us out of the
country and say we can’t come back again
and then we would be able to finish our movie.
There is a little bit of that fear, too, which
I think is a little unfair in a way.
Not unfair…but we are trying to do with
our movie what is best for Cambodia which
is shed light on this sort of issue because
a lot of these illegal fisherman are really
what they are doing besides destroying the
environment which as Westerners is why were
are probably initially drawn to it.
But in terms of the people in the country,
there’s a lot of people who live off of
the ocean and subsistence fishing who are
having a harder and harder time being able
to do that because the fish are disappearing,
the habitat for the fish is disappearing,
they’ll put their crab posts in or their
own smaller nets that just get taken up by
the big fishing boats and they lose their
livelihood and they also get into skirmishes
with these larger illegal fisherman and so
there is people there who kind of need this
to happen for them (not so much for the movie)
but for the work that Paul and Matt are doing
and so getting that out there to the larger
audience is going to be very helpful.
And I would hope that the people in charge
of the country would understand that’s what
we are trying to do and we’re not there
to make them look bad but to try to uh…like…correct
some injustices, perhaps?
Stephanie Lincoln: Yeah and….[doorbell rings].
Christopher Smith: The mail is here!